et
une créatrice de mode visionnaire une
usine reconvertie dans le jeu vidéo un
restaurant humaniste et un vélodrome qui
fait tourner les têtes
bienvenue à roubaix pour ce nouveau
numéro d'itinérance 27 % de chômage
un habitant sur deux en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
si l'ancienne capitale du textile est
aujourd'hui la ville la plus pauvre de
france
les roubaisiens redouble d'imagination
pour faire que leur ville retrouve un
peu de couleurs pour commencer rencontre
avec notre grand témoin c'est une femme
roubaisienne d'adoption cette créatrice
de mode n'a pas choisi le nord par
hasard elle y puise son inspiration et
imagine une ligne de vêtements
respectueuse des hommes et de
l'environnement
toi
j'vais
c'est le
dieu
il
qui a dit que le textile était
définitivement mort à roubaix on a
maintenant rendez vous dans une boutique
qui fait de la résistance et d'une
guerre jolie facile
bonjour yale bonjour je lui dis merci
beaucoup on est dans votre boutique où
vous commercialisez votre marque depuis
deux ans l'herbe rouge qu'est ce qu'on
trouve ici dans vos rayons on trouve des
vêtements de vos vêtements dans des
matières écologiques fabriqués de
manière responsable dans la pure
tradition de l'art puis des vêtements
faciles à porter de qualité et qui sont
utilisables pour tous les moments de la
journée
eh bien rien je vais tout de suite
essayé cette unique pour voir si je me
sens bien vous avez un petit fou j'ai un
petit format ce sera peut-être un petit
peu mais on va essayer d'avoir une idée
déjà
alors à rien on se sent en effet
vraiment très à l'aise dans ses
vêtements une sensation de confort chez
vous tout part de la matière tout à fait
nous sommes des chercheurs de batelière
des chercheurs de matière est exactement
tout part du terroir en fait finalement
un petit peu comme le bon vin
donc du coup on a quoi comme matière la
du coton bio on à du coton bio alors
donc il n'ya pas de pesticides
herbicides
ensuite bon sur l'été jean n'est pas là
mais on est très attaché au lin bio
l'eau ou au lin biologique je rappelle
également que le nord de la france et
une est une terre de culture de l'art et
donc on est sur un prix moyen de gamme
avec de la qualité haut de gamme alors
le prix moyen d'une pièce est de 100
euros chez les scythes c'est une pièce
comme vous avez pu le constater quand
même avec de la qualité avec une
histoire avec de la création définition
on est ici à roubaix
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens de
s'acheter une pièce comme celle ci il ya
un choix à faire et ce que je préfère un
petit peu moins mais mieux
mais est-ce qu'en même temps si je suis
quoi cadre moyen est ce que je suis
obligé de excusez-moi de m'habiller avec
de la merde quand il ya des pièces qui
sont pas chères il ya toujours un
problème derrière c'est qu'à un moment
ou un autre il ya la teinture qui est
pas qui est pas propre qui va pas faire
du bien celui qu'il porte c'est qu'on a
fait que la fabrication n'a pas été
responsable c'est à dire qu'on a fait
travailler n'importe comment n'importe
où n'importe qui donc nous on essaie
juste de remettre du sens et à roubaix
n'ont cessé c'est possible bien sûr on
va pas habillé tout là toute la terre
entière alors ariel la ville et la
région ont misé sur le développement
culturel ici le louvre qui s'est
installée à lens les terry qui ont été
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
le musée de la piscine ici à roubaix et
all c'est peu l'institut du monde arabe
a ouvert une antenne à la fin de l'année
je crois vous n'êtes pas encore allé
sous propose qu'on a eue le découvrir
ensemble
elle est répartie direction lima arriver
c'est nous
vous pensez vraiment vous que la
troisième révolution textile c'est pour
demain avec une passionnée bien sûr la
troisième est la troisième révolution
industrielle du textile
elle passera par le nord elle passera
par le loft parce que parce que le nord
a besoin de trouver des solutions et le
nord a toujours rebondi dans dans les
moments difficiles
ariel on est là dans le quartier de
l'union
l'ancien quartier textile de roubaix qui
est en train de sortir de terre de se
transformer on est vraiment dans ce que
vous appelez vous le petit berlin tout à
fait on ressent vraiment des vibrations
de de berlin après la chute du mur quand
tous vers le scc mise en route pour se
reconstruire
et puis c'est vous c'est bourré
d'émotion pour les gens qui ont reconnu
la désindustrialisation du textile ce
qu'on se trouve quand même sur sur la
zone de l'union où il y avait jusqu'en
2003 2004
lusine du peignage de la tossée qui pour
être à l'aise à un peignage de la lettre
c'est vraiment impressionnant on voit on
voit le passé ici qui est encore présent
ces restes du sinn
un peu mieux ré les vitres un peu cassée
on sent vraiment qu'il ya eu une vie
ouvrière is here we r qui n'a pas
toujours été facile mais les gens à la
tossée était vraiment comme eux comme
une famille il ya aussi toute la fin de
la phase d'immigration après 1945 ou des
personnes en provenance d'algérie ou du
maroc sont venus prêter main forte à ses
usines
justement c'est ici qu'a choisi de
s'installer
l'institut du monde arabe l'antenne on
va voir tout de suite on y va
oh ça j'aime beaucoup c'est beau c'est
une problème c'est qu'on a toujours
envie de toucher des crs l'écriture
alors il est dans le développement
durable
prix
ariel des expositions des colloques des
cours de langue sur le modèle parisien
ici l'institut du monde arabe se veut un
pont entre les cultures française et
arabe
il y en a besoin dans cette ville où les
vagues d'immigration du maghreb se sont
succédé oui c'est ça me semble une
évidence quoi donc la population
d'origine maghrébine
fait partie de la ville de
de roubaix mais par contre je ne pense
que l'institut du monde arabe se doit
pas simplement d'être l'antenne de paris
et je ne dois pas simplement d'être un
lieu culturel ça doit être un lieu de
rencontre je sais caribe par exemple il
ya encore des femmes qui font des
superbes tapis berbères donc pourquoi ne
pas s adresse aussi un dieu que les gens
vont pouvoir se réapproprier artistes
famille enfants toujours dans la
transmission vers 6 heures
dans ce quartier de l'union tout ou
presque a été rasée mais un homme
résiste je ne pouvais pas passer ici
sans m'arrêter
chez salah
bonjour monsieur vous avez voulu rester
ouverts ici plutôt tout le temps jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours
pas question de partir non non non non
vous vous avez dit chez salah je ne
vendrai pas on vous a proposé de
l'argent pour partir pas besoin de
largeur l'agent farand qu'il soit là je
dirais que je la joue et c'est bon alors
y'a pas besoin de plus chez salah s'est
ouvert depuis 1935 e65 ça fait quelques
années à l'époque il y avait encore des
usines à côté qui est ce qu'ils venaient
chez vous c'était quoi l'ambiance dans
ce bar avant je sais que c'est une des
études les clients des usines à l'époque
où il y avait encore des yeux qui
tournait avec 88 personnes et maintenant
il n'y a plus rien c'était quoi
l'ambiance dans le bar on vous aura un
juge pour le cuivre un peu d'attention
il y avait beaucoup de vies dans ce lieu
est dans le quartier à l'imoca
s'émerveille d'embûches
attention permanente 90 motos pour se
rappeler le bon vieux temps vous avez
encore la machine qui fait de la musique
fonctionne encore ça tourne ah ouais
auger niel dans ses repas je la faisais
pas danser votre femme
non non pas de danse
c'était pour parents deux les autres
jalouse
d'un côté le temps presse car et et de
l'autre des drapeaux dans les rues comme
autant de déclarations d'amour pour une
ville qui cumule pourtant les handicaps
roubaix capitale du textile au début du
20e siècle a vu ses usines permet et la
population partir en un siècle la ville
a perdu près de 60000 habitants a
récemment classé ville la plus pauvre de
france la petite voisine de l'île ne
mérite pas pour autant le titre de ville
la plus déprimé signe des temps qui
changent certaines start up
informatiques ont en quelques années
crever des plafonds suivez le guide
hsbc l'histoire du petit poucet
roubaisiens qui aujourd'hui côtoient les
géants du jeu vidéo je suis maintenant
rendez vous avec olivier compte le
directeur général d'ankama mais avant je
finis ma partie bienvenue jeune homme
retrouvé damphousse
devient payant est entré dans la légende
olivier bonjour bonjour je lis okama
c'est l'histoire de trois amis
roubaisiens qui décide de créer des jeux
vidéo il ya 13 ans c'est un peu une
success story à l'américaine
il ya effectivement il ya 13 ans donc
c'est trois amis qui ont commencé à
travailler pour une web agency
il y'en avait deux qui était passionné
de jeux vidéo etc ont commencé à bosser
le soir la nuit sur des histoires une
amérique qui est un grand rêveur et qui
voulait raconter des histoires un qui
était plus dans le développement
donc ils ont commencé à créer un jeu est
un jeu online
et comme parfois ça arrive et on a en
fait on a une expression dans notre
industrie qui est moi qui me tient à
coeur on dit toujours on n'est pas à
l'abri d'un succès et c'est ce qui s'est
passé un jour leur banquier les appeler
ni voilà je comprends pas vous avez fait
un revirement dans la nuit qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et c est le jeu est partie
qu'on et ankama a décollé aujourd'hui
c'est 450 salariés
trois millions de joueurs dans le monde
et un titre phare dofus d'un jeu en
ligne
tout le monde peut jouer alors
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment même 500
employés on a on a notre siège à roubaix
et on c'est important pour nous parce
qu'on n'oublie pas nos racines et c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important mais on a aussi des studios
d'animation qui sont à paris on a des
studios au japon à singapour au canada à
sao paulo donc aujourd'hui c'est une
belle entreprise méconnue mais une belle
entreprise vos concurrents sont japonais
anglais américains comment un petit
studio roubaisien fait pour tenir tête
aux géants du secteur on a une vivier de
talents créatifs en terme d'animation et
d'animation 3d 2d etc etc
d'infographiste je préfère rester tous
les to et tous les métiers de notre
industrie mais on est on est on est pas
mauvais les français ne sont pas moins
maintenant pour être tout à fait honnête
c'est extrêmement dur aujourd'hui de
faire des jeux vidéo en france
pour dire les choses comme elles sont la
france a fait un choix et son choix il
n'est pas de pousser l'industrie du jeu
vidéo et de l'entente pays
j'imagine que vous manquez de temps mais
à l'occasion vous jouez au jeu vidéo
j'ai beaucoup joué maintenant avec l'âge
on
on a un peu moins le temps de jouer avec
le boulot j'ai les enfants les machins
trucs et donc non et oui parce que parce
que je joue plus quatre heures par jour
aux trois heures par jour comme avant
mais je continue à jouer notre vrai boss
et nos communautés nos joueurs donc on
écoute vraiment ce qu'ils lisent
et quand ils nous font des remarques on
vérifie ses robes à quoi merci à vous
nini
et
et des briques partout et pourtant s'ils
viennent en france change de peau c'est
bien roubaix et si la rénovation urbaine
a touché 60 % des habitants et la moitié
du territoire de la commune en sept ans
pas loin de 185 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour détruire ou réhabiliter le
patrimoine si typique du nord en plein
centre ville
pour une fois le bâtiment n'est pas en
briques et en bois et en paille mais
leur projet et solide autour d'un
restaurant la coopérative baraka offre
un emploi durable à ceux qui n'en ont
pas
le petit
bonjour
julie ça travaille
bonjour fait du mal à chanter david ont
scellé leur d'apurer à la main yako au
menu ce midi pour montrer emain suspens
pour les deux coups qu'on a mis en place
un pool dans marianne et enflamme les
jets ont fait un gratin de pâtes
habitons chèvre etc la noisette original
yati si dans le dos rond mais du
maroilles avec la vie en main
bonjour pierre bonjour alors je viens
des cuisines ça s'active à son bon ou
excellent centre est bon c'est son
maroilles produit local tous les jours
un nouveau menu à base de produits frais
la coopérative baraka c'est d'abord un
restaurant c'est un restaurant pour
faire autre chose mais c'est vrai que ce
qu'on voit en premier et ce qui doit
marcher ce qui doit une bond tous les
jours et frais et avec les valeurs qu'on
essaie de mettre dedans c'est à dire au
maximum bio on est dans une logique de
grimper on est à 80% on veut aller à
100% c'est le restaurant on avait envie
de se dire on va faire une entreprise
dont le seul but sera de fabriquer du
bien commun de dégager de l'argent pour
permettre d'autres choses employez des
gens qui ont eu un parcours d'insertion
donc des difficultés pour arriver à
l'emploi mais les employés en contrat en
cdi de droit commun et puis dans ce lieu
là après inventé tout ce qu'on a envie
d'inventer en termes de des changes de
partage 2-2 non marchand voilà et donc
mais s'il reste au marche pas si la
location de salles aux entreprises pour
faire des séminaires des événements
extérieurs ne fonctionne pas tout ça
s'arrête parce que c'est dire on conçoit
un modèle qui nous permet de mettre le
marchand au service du non marchand
ces emplois c'est un petit geste dans
une ville est en grande difficulté
c'est sûr que c'est pas les cinq emplois
qu'on a créé ici enfin qu' à temps plein
qui vont changer la situation du chômage
à roubaix mais on arrive quand même à
créer une dynamique et 100 sociétaires
ont mis de l'argent dans cette aventure
ils ont pas mis un petit peu ils ont
mille deux cent mille euros pour que ça
existe et on y arrive et ça je pense que
c'est un mot américain petit peu
compliqué mais en power man comme on dit
la capacité d'un de ses pas un concept
très français mais la communauté à se
prendre en main et à faire des choses
en corse et les derniers préparatifs
l'avant le service voilà exactement là
on termine les cartes ont fait les
quantités de stocks et les torchons
ensuite la mise en place ça fait combien
de temps que vous êtes ici boucher et
baraka alors ça fait à peu près deux ans
tu as le sentiment que c'est une chance
pour toi d'avoir sept ans plan là moi
qui équivalent paris en fait déjà paris
ça peut compliquer la roubaix c'est très
compliqué qu'est ce que tu as trouvé ici
qu'on ne trouve pas ailleurs
ça restera bios et on n'en trouve pas
partout c'est convivial aussi préparer à
d'autres restaurants il ya beaucoup de
clients qui reviennent très souvent donc
c'est familial mais c'est ce qui est
bien c'est qu'on fait un briefing tous
les toutes les semaines
donc ce qui va prendre mais sur le tapis
le jour même et ensuite ça repart de
plus belle ça se passe très bien
c'est vrai que c'était une matinée aussi
bien chargé en travail qu'on se conçoit
nombreux parce qu'il ya un niveau de
stress quand même à vendre donc ça va
s'arranger pour que le problème
électrique à l'aide avant pierre bon
service ce midi il ya eu un petit
moineau un petit peu moins de monde que
ce qu'on attendait et on a fait 80
couverts mais on a fait 80 couverts en
une heure à peu près pour un chiffre
d'affaires on a fait 1400 euros toutes
taxes donc c'est vraiment l'objectif on
est content qui est ce qui vient chez
baraka des gens du quartier et des bobos
des hommes d'affaires c'est quoi des
bobos g à partir de quel montant on est
beau
non c'est déjà aussi tu content parce
que j'ai jamais fait de business plans
avant les écoles de joris forme passe
mais c'est ce qu'on avait imaginé c'est
le coeur de cible c'est des salariés au
bénin il ya trente mille personnes qui
viennent chaque jour travaillé à roubaix
et qui n'y habitent pas eux ils sont
solvables
eux ils ont l'argent pour manger ils ont
des tickets resto et caetera et donc
cédé essentiellement à midi vraiment des
salariés et une grosse zone franche ici
hein c'est là je crois que c'est la
seule de france en centre ville et
certains soit vous proposer des
activités à ceux qui le souhaitent
oui c'est ça c'est à dire que par
exemple ce soir il ya le fab lab c'est
qu'on prend c'est comment dire une
activité
bricolage de faire soi même et ça c'est
thierry qui est venu nous voir qui a dit
ah j'aime bien la démarche de barack à
moi je suis supporter de tels projets
est ce que l'on pourrait imaginer un
truc le vendredi soir c'est fab lab un
atelier de fabrication et bien sûr on va
aller faire un tour pour voir ce que ça
donne merci beaucoup pierre
comme la lumière ces cas là je
m'essayais contre un bon sortir y soit
alors ici c'est une tout autre cuisine
que vous proposer des ateliers gratuits
et ouverts à tous où on va pouvoir
fabriquer ses propres aux objets c'est
ça exactement
sait on ce qu'on appelle les petits
ateliers fab lab avec cet objet
emblématique qui est l'imprimante 3d
donc une imprimante 3d qui a été
construit ici à la baraka et qui permet
de faire des activités autour de la
créativité la création et fabrication
d'objets ont réparé ces objets on fait
des petites cages des petits gadgets des
figurines heures on s'amuse avec la
technologie et n'importe qui peut venir
ici
oui c'est l'idée de deux de ses sept
ateliers fab lab c'est que ça s'adresse
vraiment à tout le monde aux jeunes
avouent des outils des matières et une
imprimante 3d c'est la première fois que
j'en vois une qu'est ce qu'on va faire
comment le geste soit en fait un petit
robot bleu et on va aller chercher un
modèle dans une base de données sur un
site 1 voilà un site auquel tout le
monde a accès donc on est bien d'accord
haut débit à rien
et donc on va faire une pause et ont pu
aussi réparer des objets exactement des
objets du quotidien ce qu'on appelait
des beats audio qui sont cassés qui sont
perdus généralement c'est comme une
télécommande de télévision sur le bois
typique qui s'en va en premier
eh bien on peut recréer son vote est
pile on peut recréer ddd petit support
pour des étagères qui sont cassés on
peut créer des talons c'est un peu une
autre façon de consommer oui forcément
une autre façon de consommer qui fait
réfléchir justement sur ce qu'on fait
sur le geste d'achat qui voilà qui
s'intéressent au développement durable à
comment on peut dans nos comportements
quotidiens faire en sorte que moins de
déchets
thierry ça y est c'est fini c'est vrai
c'est cuit barak alors où s'écrivent
exactement et bah écoute
avant de se quitter on va faire une
petite photo tous ensemble avec les
participants de l'atelier c'est la
tradition dans l'émission la photo
souvenir un deux trois bacs à caracas
peut-être qu'un jour thierry et sa bande
fabriqueront des pavés comme ceux qui
jalonnent le parcours du paris roubaix
cette classique cycliste longue de 300
km
réputé pour ses secteurs pavés
redoutable dont la fameuse trouée
d'arenberg qui décime le peloton chaque
année qu'il pleuve qu'il vente
et ça fait cent dix huit ans m
c'est ici sur les pavés roubaisien que
les galériens du nord finissent leur
route après 300 km et juste à côté de
l'ancien vélodrome à ciel ouvert il ya
maintenant un tout nouveau vélodrome
ultra moderne avec un toit
com
bonjour arnaud bonjour alors j'ai la
chance d'être aux côtés d'un champion
olympique de cyclisme sur piste champion
du monde et surtout le premier homme à
avoir parcouru un kilomètre en moins
d'une minute sur une piste c'est ça le
premier est descendu sous la barre
mythique de la minute
ancien champion du monde et champion
olympique parce que ça reste ça reste à
vie quand même
aujourd'hui vous êtes le directeur de ce
vélodrome rouvet et le vélo c'est une
longue histoire d'amour une belle
histoire
c'est une belle histoire d'amour c'est
une longue histoire qui a commencé avec
bien sûr le cyclisme sur route les
arrivées du tour de france à la belle
époque le paris roubaix qui fait
aujourd'hui la notoriété du cyclisme /
ou b et la page continue avec avec ce
vélodrome couvert qui fait maintenant
partie de la culture cycliste du nord
pas de calais et qui incorpore encore pu
trouver dans l'histoire du vélo
en diable alors non ce vélodrome il a
été inauguré à l'été 2012
c'est une piste aux normes
internationales qui va très vite
l'objectif c'était d'accueillir qui les
pontes du milieu
tous les types d'utilisateurs le haut
niveau avec les plus grands champions
les équipes nationales les équipes
professionnelles chose qu'on fait très
régulièrement ici mais aussi les
utilisateurs
loisirs les amateurs du vélo les
cyclotouristes ceux qui ont tout
simplement envie de découvrir une belle
discipline
donc ce vélodrome est ouvert à tous et
permet tous les types d'utilisation à
l'eau pour aller sur la piste il faut un
vélo bien sûr mais pas n'importe lequel
il est très particulière c'est vrai que
c'est pas le vélo qu'on achète au
supermarché ou dans des magasins
spécialisés la plus grande particularité
d'un vélo sur piste et bien sûr on n'a
pas de frein rien pas de dérailleur et
ce qui fait le vélo de piste
c'est tout simplement ce pignon fixe
c'est à dire que quand on roule on ne
peut pas s'arrêter de pédaler le frein
et d'accélérateur sont au niveau des
cuisses et les cuisses qui travaillent
là que ça chauffe
alors je crois vous proposer des
baptêmes je vais aller tester pour voir
les sensations n'est pas se relever le
professionnel financier
on va d'abord commencer à un stade un
peu plus accessible sur ce genre de vélo
hockey et binbin quelques minutes plus
tard sur la scène
pas du tout ils permettent en
c'est ça ah oui en ce blog complet par
dedans occupez-vous c'est rassurant
comme ça est parti alors qu'il
accélèrera plaire à tous complets
annoncés pour la médecine
les
j'ai réussi à faire un virage à bien
sans problème mais là on va essayer au
dessus de la noire et en faire un tour
complet au dessus des noirs se tient
sans problème regarder droit devant vous
on va réussir
elle a du caractère votre collègue
à
un peu
il ya vu way aussi bon et bonnes
sensations donc là on va dire que tu
étais à 35 km toi tu montes à combien la
sur la piste
sam est serré arrivée sur des efforts
très rapide
quand j'étais sportif de haut niveau de
monter à environ 75 km heure d'accord et
encore un petit peu de travail
c'est bien ça je vais m'acheter sur la
photo avec vous mon diplôme en vélo je
suis pas bien entouré la l'habitude chez
les hôtesses
ils font la bise black heart donc là je
pense que la scène avec mes 30 km
vainqueur d'étape maillot vert la totale
voilà cette émission touche à sa fin
vous mais vous l'avez vue n'est pas que
cette ville 17 et des prix mais les
roubaisiens attachés à leur site et
redouble d'imagination pour changer
l'image qui leur colle à la peau on ne
pouvait pas terminer cette émission sans
vous faire découvrir ou redécouvrir le
musée de la piscine à roubaix une
ancienne piscine publique art déco
édifié en 1932 et reconverti en musée
d'art et d'industrie en 2001 une
métamorphose réussie c'est ce qu'on
souhaite à cette ville à bientôt pour
une nouvelle balade dans une france en
attente